دعا الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
الى توفير دعم دولي كثيف للصومال لتجاوز
الاوضاع الانسانيه الصعبه التي تعيشها
البلاد واكد غوتيريش الذي وصل الى مقاديشو
في زياره تمتد ليومين ان البلاد تدفع ثمن
التغير المناخي ووصفها باكبر ضحيه لهذه
الازمه العالميه كما وصل الامين العام
للامم المتحده الى مدينه بدواء جنوب غربي
البلاد حيث سيزور مخيمات النازحين في
المنطقه
بما ان الصومال لا يساهم في التغيير
المناخي فان الصوماليين من ضمن اكبر
ضحاياه ومن هنا ادق ناقوس الخطر في الحاجه
الى دعم دولي كبير بسبب الحالات الانسانيه
الصعبه التي تواجهها البلاد ودعم دولي
كبير من اجل بناء قدرات الامنيه للحكومه
الصوماليه واعاده الاستقرار والتنميه في
البلاد